poi la tela toscan paliero se venite
questo nuovo video di j
chiunque ancora non ha preso un cazzo
perché non c'ho voglia di fare un cazzo
e manco rifatto letto anche ragazzi
siamo nuovo video sul loculo swift che è
la prima volta che l'utilizzo in questa
bella stanza una vuota
iniziamo subito prima che ci ripensi
siamo ragazzi questo si chiama buffo in
the city non si vede un cazzo come
quello che testano ma se roccazzo
mabanckou e colloquio stripped al nostro
gioco a quello ma ragazzi siete scemi
c'è un eolie a 8 cent a superman che
cazzo st succi questo stesso giornale
seriamente ragazzi il gioco si chiama
ufo in the city non c'è né un ufo nella
crew street che serve spiegatemelo
famiglia
salve è nostro qua io sono qua non
funziona loculo street alieni del cazzo
melo riparate voi grazie vedi che stanno
arrivando a ripararlo con sé perché lo
sono avanti
loro hanno già inventato la realtà
virtuale quindi sanno qual è il problema
e me lo risolvono vero zio sembra un
preservativo volante non s'è capito il 6
ma tu zia li hai visti cioè non è andato
discover endo solo io perché cazzo c'è
un barbone che si rotola adesso avete
capito perché gli alieni non vengono a
visitarci stavo scherzando zio non opero
non mi prendere troppo sul serio per
carità e la madonna quanto è grosso sto
preservativo chi cazzo è c'è un barbone
che si rotola e vorrei capire il senso
mi ripari loculo per favore ma la cosa
bella è che la gente non ne frega un
cazzo celu credo continua allontanarsi
per terra
se ne sono accorti adesso mi sento
la madonna
ve ne siete accorti adesso che ci sono
gli alieni si se ne sono accorti che mi
sa che ci ha messo un po però se ne sono
accorti becker ragazzi siamo su a
expected to die like to continuino
perfetto ci siamo ragazzi non ha
l'obiettivo di questo gioco lo spiego
prima così almeno poi si capisce c'è una
macchina su un aereo devo riuscire a
buttarmi giù dall'aereo con la macchina
e poi la macchina c'è un paracadute che
mi salva veramente sono intrappolati in
un aereo devo buttarmi giù punto ma
riesco a prenderla roba con la lingua
fantastico non datemi mai più in mano un
videogioco non capito bene che cazzo ci
devo fare queste cose un cd di di gigi
d'alessio snell games giochi snelli per
bambini macrì il tasto start stava
dietro tutta la merda fanta grazie
grazie mille
perfetto ci siamo ragazzi non sa che
cos'è star devo guidare moning ci sono
dei pulsanti che non so che cosa cazzo
servono quindi non mi far guidare per
cortesia poi siamo su un aeroplano caam
questa macchina alle armi fantastico no
non pensate male ragazzi questa qua in
realtà è un ago pro è un ago pro che io
tengo sempre sul sedile di fianco perché
nel caso mi passi john travolta davanti
lo film è come la chiama il mio annuncio
la chiave ragazzi è la madonna di pigmei
aspetto già un attimo qua che passiamo
da mcdonald se volete qualcosa vite melo
che io passo con una volta e non torno
qui veniamo al mcdrive alla chiave la
chiave ragazzi si infila perfetto si
gira
mera visione questo tasto si è
illuminato quindi lo schiaccio anche
figo ti fa la plastica al naso
stamattina e senti stronzo di merda
evitiamo di fare la madonna cazzo devo
fare costarmi perché ho capito io cosa
fare la mia vita ma non è che mi sento a
[ __ ] che io io la bomba che etichetta
la lascio qui si può partire davanti
avanti perfetto dal fotoreporter oh mio
dio
no no no scherzavo scherzavo ciao dai
fuochi ai soldi che tanto non servono
ecco ma il coltello che posso usare
anche per disinnescare la bomba
ok vari sfuggiti articolo
non so disinnescare bombe ok quindi
ragazzi o capitava fermi che ho capito
cosa devo farle o disinnesca la bomba
perfetto non ho capito bene come palmesi
filo blu [ __ ] ho provato tutti i
fili quella era quello giallo ok a posto
non ancora stati gettando però ci siamo
ragazzi non ci posso credere
perfetto o miti o meno male ce la
possiamo fare
mi aprì che sto portellone di merda per
cortesia o a casa ma no ma no se gerotto
[ __ ] però brinda delle granate
fumogene ma ditelo subito maledizione
altri soldi soldi insomma
cacciavite fatto l'ho presa ho preso io
so che se ho fatto un cacciavite invito
scritto la macchina ragazzi smonto tutta
la macchina ci prova ma cazzo ma
l'obiettivo ragazzi a uscire dall aero
ci sto provando in tutti i modi di qua a
master reset perfetto per viaggio
sestri sharing poi penso mai adesso le
armi quali armi quindi se io schiaccio
questa cosa qui alla madonna
io ho delle fumogeni posso mettere
queste cosette e morale
ciao cosa era mica sono deficiente lui
sono usato i gas da solo contro ragazzi
latinamente volendo credo è sì perfetto
si apre il portellone forza
ma chi è ce l'ho fatta stai zitto posso
andare giù
stiamo già precipitando quindi io mi
muovo mi muovo veloce
[Musica]
ragazzi è stata la cosa più strana che
io abbia mai fatto in tutta la mia vita
cosa strana è la madonna sono a trip hop
mingardi come sta nicchia e non funziona
più vecchio hard rock e bella partenza
che vedo un pollo capo un 12 a tua
sorella prima cosa a sé mister presse
nichi to play casa mia dove cazzo si sa
a che bella la renault ciao ragazzi o
mio dio io non ho investito decente che
merda non è per la testa e per carità va
bene che sono senza testa fantastico
madonna quanto son macro so più magro
qualche nella vita reale e fantastico so
usare le gambe
avete visto tutti in fatemi l'applauso
che cazzo guardi a bere sigle stai e
senti ma che anche lui è molto magro
intorno denutrito parliamone cioè
ascoltami che bello che fai allora
inizia a fare pratica finiti pronto allo
ior e parte che sono indietreggiato che
manca michael jackson calmiamoci subito
che morgan a tali uno schiaffo che uso
le tue ossa come xilofono a eccole
mantello rosa cielo no ma io sono un
torero professionista devi raggiungere
ma ce la fa il suo perfetto ma mi sposto
perfetto mi sono già rotto i [ __ ]
i ragazzi sono contento del fatto che
voi apprezziate il fatto che io vi porti
sempre dei videogiochi della madonna
indaga spero che vi sia piaciuto e cosa
sento seguito è piaciuta strumento è un
mi piace anche la pace di facebook che
non evita a trattare per schizzare sensi
dischetto ci vediamo fossimo video e le
ragazze ricordatevi di preservativi sono
un po più piccoli di quella roba lì
dipende poi se c'hai il pene di rocco
quello è un altro discorso
vabbè la lega è bella